what's up guys in this video I'm going
to show you how to program connect for
in Python by the end of these videos
we'll have built something that looks
like this it's a simple two-player
connect for game with graphics I think
this is a really good exercise for your
beginner to intermediate level Python
programmers who want to build their
skills I'll just finish up a game real
quick just so you can see how this fully
works as you can see I have the diagonal
and it says player 1 went in school
we're gonna do something a little bit
simpler and then build up to that
graphic based connect for game it's a
command line connect for game where you
actually manually type in numbers to
drop your pieces so you see the 1 there
the 2 cetera alright so let's start
building that just quickly I want to
mention that I'll be programming in
Python 3 and then using sublime text 2
as my editor I posted a link to a video
on how to set up these things in the
description so one of the first
questions I ask myself when I was
writing this game is what is the best
way to represent the board so if I drag
on a connect 4 board real quick you can
see that it is 6 rows by 7 columns and
to me this looks like the perfect
structure to represent as a matrix in
Python so that's what we'll do so we'll
define a function called create board
and that's not gonna accept any inputs
and then we're gonna make a a matrix of
all zeros with the dimensions 6 by 7 and
to help us do this we're gonna import a
package called numpy and if you haven't
already installed this you can open up a
terminal window and just type in pip
install numpy and as you can see I
already have it so we're going to use
this as followers or as a board equals
numpy zeros and that's gonna make a
matrix of all zeros which is good for
our initial state and then the
dimensions six rows by seven columns
cool and then we just need to return
that forward and we can test to make
sure that worked by doing the following
create board and then prints forward and
as you can see if I run Oh what happened
as you can see if I run that
we we do in fact have this 6 by 7 matrix
of all zeros so that looks good we can
begin writing the mean game loop now so
we're gonna write a loop that says while
not game over
and so our loop is gonna be running as
long as this game over variable is false
and the only way it becomes true as if
someone has a foreign row so we need to
initialize the game over to be false to
begin with
it goes false and the only way that's
gonna switch to true is if someone got a
four in a row so now we're going to need
to we're also going to want to real
quick make our board initialize before
we start the game just so we have
something to put pieces into so we have
our board we have our game over variable
and now we're going to want to be able
to ask for player one input and then
we're also going to want to eventually
be able to ask ask for player two input
so this kind of leads us to the problem
of oh how do we differentiate between
whether it's player one or player 2's
turn so role is going to define another
variable up here called turn that's just
going to initialize to 0 so what we're
gonna say is if turn equals equals zero
then we're gonna want to ask for player
1 input alright so in Python there's a
function a built-in function called
input as you can see it highlights blue
for me so we're going to say selection
equals input and then we're say player 1
make your selection so this is what the
player 1 is gonna say and then the way
we're going to initialize this game is
we're gonna just say they can type in
between 0 and 6 so this is what the
player 1 should see so if I build this
you see we run to this error so this is
because sublime text doesn't accept this
input function so my workaround for this
was I installed a package in sublime
called sublime repl I'll put a link in
the description of how to and
all this and I can run the input
function through that so now you can see
player 1 make your selection 3 and
doesn't do anything with that input
right now but you can see that it's
asking me that and I can type in hit
enter all right cool so we also just
want to make sure that it saves our
selection properly so we're going to
print selection and I also just want to
see you know if I type in a number does
it actually give me the number or does
it give me a string that represents the
number so I'm going to also print in
type of selection and I just want to see
what we're getting so I'm going to run
that again and as you can see ever again
but we're gonna go to sublime repl and
the link is in the description as I just
said run current file so to and as you
can see it gets to but it says it's a
string so we're gonna want to make sure
that it's actually a integer so we can
just surround this with int input and
this should work so let's see run that
again and you can also run this through
the command line so if you run this in
your terminal go to the directory that
the file is in and type in Python and
then filename it will also run just as
I'm running it in this sublime repl
player1 make your selection 3 cool and
now you see it says 3 and it says the
class of that is an int so that looks
good to me
so now you can save some sort of
selection from the user and you can also
edit this so that it requires you to
make a specific number type in a
specific number but we'll just leave it
as like we're imagine our players are
following the directions right now all
right
cool we have that and then we're also
going to want to be able to ask for
player two's input so that's going to
happen else otherwise so if the turn is
not equal to 0 then we want to ask for
player 2 inputs or selection equals and
we'll just copy this from above
and we'll just have the changes just to
say player to make your selection all
right cool and now at the end of the
turn no matter whose turn it is we're
gonna want to increase our turn by one
so turn plus or plus equals one so I'll
make it increment it by 1 and then we're
also what we're gonna also want to do is
we're gonna just make this odd even so
we're gonna use mod division so it's
going to be turn mod to turn equals turn
mod 2 and this is just basically making
it go take the remainder of whatever our
turn is divided by 2 so this was just
gonna alternate it between 0 and 1 so it
will alternate between player ones turn
and player two's turn so let's just see
if this works properly so we're gonna
run this build python kern file player 1
make your selection to player 2 make
your selection for player 1 make your
section 2 oh that looks good it's
alternating between our player 1 and
player 2 cool okay and now we're going
to want to start building our actual
functionality we're gonna want to be
able to make this selection right here
actually drop a piece into our board so
I'm going to find another function up
here called definition drop piece and we
might define a couple functions so maybe
have a little drop piece and I will just
do pass for now and maybe we'll also
have like is valid location so that will
check whatever number that the player
typed in we'll check to see if that's a
valid location we'll also define a
function called get next open row and
how all these functions are going to
work together is as follows so it all
begins with the player making a
selection the 0 to 6 here represents the
column that they want to drop their
piece in so maybe I'm more appropriate
title for this would be Co L
representing column C you well
next we're going to take this column and
the current board we have and pass it
into this is valid location function so
board calm and to visualize how we can
check to see if the column they selected
is a valid location we will print out
the board real quick so as you can see
imagine this is the zeroth row is the
first row second row all the way up to
the fifth row here and then this is the
0th column first column second column
etc we're starting at 0 as our first
index so if we wanted to check if the
column that the user selected let's just
assume that the user always types in a
valid number 0 to 6 if we wanted to
check to see if it's valid all we need
to do is make sure that this top row for
that specific column is not been filled
so let's imagine that we're putting ones
in for player 1 going and twos in for
player 2 going so if this top row is
still 0 for the specific column we
selected then we know that it's OK for
us to drop a piece in that row or in
that column it hasn't been filled all
the way to the top so do that so this is
the fifth row so all I'm gonna do is
just check to see whether or not the
position at the fifth row and let's say
you know whatever column we select is 0
and if it is that means the column is
still free if it's not then that's not a
validation want to have the user try
something else
so to do that lets just do board so
we're gonna return board and then the
the row is 5 and the column is whatever
the user selected so here so and we're
going to make sure that's equal equals 0
so if that's true then we're good -
we're good to let them drop the piece
there if that's not true that means the
column has been filled up all the way
and one thing I'll note that will
probably change in a future video is
that
it's kind of getting messy my code a
little bit with just throwing these
random numbers here all the way all over
the place and programming these are
called magic numbers you kind of don't
know where they come from so I'll clean
those up in some of the future videos in
this series so return board five column
equals equals zero and that is just
checking to make sure that that column
has an empty slot okay so now that we've
gotten the valid location let's get the
next open row in that column so if we
think back to our board
that's just checking to see when we drop
it and let's say the 0th column here on
the left it's checking to see which row
of these if the piece will fall on so to
do this we're going to write a quick
little loop so we're going to do four
and we're all set the pass in the board
and the column into this one so the loop
we're going to write here is for R and
range and I'm actually going to start
getting rid of some of these magic
numbers so I'm gonna initialize a global
variable called row count and often in
Global's are capitalized just too so
that our static variables that don't
change or capitalize just to show that
they're a non changing variable so the
number of rows we have a six and the
number of columns we have is seven so
I'm gonna do for R so for row in range
so the number of rows we have so row
count and we're gonna check the board
position we're going to see if board our
position R so the column equals equals
zero then we want to return that row so
basically if the row is equal to zero so
imagine we're filling this whole board
up with ones and twos if the slot is
still zero that means it's empty still
so we're going to return the first
instance that it's empty so this R is
going to
from zero to rowcount minus one and
we're gonna return in that first case
where it equals zero
okay so now we got the next open row and
then finally what we're gonna want to do
is drop the piece so this is going to
take in the board the row and the column
and then we'll also add something we'll
just call it the piece so whether it's
player 1 or 2 going so all this is gonna
do is go forward row column equals
equals piece so we're gonna make it
fill in the board with whatever piece
that the player just dropped so let's
put this all together in our loop so
first we got the column now we're going
to check if is valid location of the
board in the column and then we can
start getting the next empty row so row
equals get next open row and that takes
in the board and column as well so get
next in pit in row board column and then
we're gonna finally drop piece and we're
gonna take in the board the row the
column and then for player 1 the piece
is just the 1 and we're gonna copy this
in to player 2 as well because player 1
and player 2 the functionality of what
they're doing is the same but we'll just
have to change the piece here to - so
now and then finally probably after the
player goes we'll probably want to print
out the board so we'll print the board
here and let's see what happens now so
tools build I'll shoot sorry sublime
repl Python run card file so player 1
selection we're gonna drop our piece
right in the middle so at 0 1 2 3 this
is the third column so 3 what happened
why did it not fill in let's figure out
what exactly went wrong there so
should have updated the board but for
some reason it did not so let's see okay
I see what I did wrong here so I
accidentally put in two equal sign here
and what we're really trying to do is an
assignment we're not trying to set see
if the board row column position is
equal to that so I didn't assign it so
now it should work so we'll rerun this
so tools of lime repl Python and current
file player 1 make your selection
we'll say go to the middle 3 player to
make your selection we'll do 3 as well
so I want to make your selection and as
you can see one issue we're having right
now is that the pieces are starting at
the top and going downwards and so the
reason for this is our convention was to
say that this was the zero zero index
but in the actual numpy they represent
this right here as the zero zero index
so I'm just gonna add an additional
function or a quick called print board
and all that's gonna do is change the
orientation so that what we're seeing is
actually the they flipped over the way
we're expecting to see a connect four
board kind of be building from bottom up
so print board and we just need to pass
in the board and all we're gonna do is
there's a command in dumpee so the
command is let me just remember it it is
n P dot flip I'm going to do board and
then you have to flip it over you have
to specify the access of a zero of the
access we're gonna flip the board over
the x-axis so that should get it upside
the the right side up again so instead
of doing print board here we're going to
now call our new print function so print
board and then board and we can also do
that down here if we want to
Prince it doesn't matter yes to start
but print board whatever okay
now let's run it again tools its primary
PL Python run current file player will
make your section 3 3 3 and as you can
see now it's building up from with ones
and twos just how we expect
this is that if I actually won this game
so as you can see I just won with player
one down the bottom the game doesn't let
me know at all that I won so we need to
implement that functionality so we're
gonna define a function called winning
move and we're gonna have that taking
the board and then the last piece that
was dropped so winning move there's a
bunch of different ways to implement
this and the way we're gonna do is not
the most efficient method but it's
probably the easiest described in a
video so that's kind of why I'm
selecting it but we're gonna manually
check all the different possible places
you could win in Connect four so all the
horizontals all the verticals and all
the diagonals and check to see if there
is a winning combination on the board
and because we're doing this after every
turn we're gonna pick up the first
instance of that winning combination so
we'll know who won probably the more
practical way would be to just check
around the spaces where the last piece
was dropped but that code got a little
bit Messier when I was doing it before
so I'm gonna just do it this way so
we're gonna first check all the
horizontal locations and to do that
we'll have a loop that iterates over the
columns so for C in range column count
and so we defined a column count up here
of and that's seven and one thing I
think would be a cool challenge for you
guys to try that I don't think my game
is going to be able to do at this point
in time is a very well designed like
connect for game you would be able to
change these numbers so like I could
change it to say like 12 or something
and this to like eight and the game
would still be able to work you still
have like I connect for game but just a
bigger board and so that's like kind of
a cool way to make sure like you've
designed things in a smart way where you
don't have just these random like magic
numbers popping up all over the place
and I'm actually gonna change this real
quick row count and
column count just cuz I'm going to try
to eliminate the magic numbers where I
can and will clean this up two row count
minus one so this is the last row the
let index with last row okay getting
back to winning move so we want to check
horizontal locations for the win so
we're gonna first loop over all the
columns and then we're also going to
have a loop over all of the rows and
what this loop is going to be over is
not every single position but over all
the possible starting positions for a
horizontal wind so if we think about our
board a horizontal wind can start this
spot this bought this but this but it
can't start here because you can't go
for over from this location so this is
our last column the third column in
terms of indices and then upwards we can
go all the way to the top vertically
because it can so this half sorry you
can't really see but we're I'm making a
box around that half is where our
starting locations can be for this first
this first check so we're iterating over
the columns so it can only be the number
of columns and then we have to subtract
three because three of those columns
couldn't actually work so we're
subtracting three off of that one and
then all the roads could work so that's
totally fine so now we're going to check
all the four in a row locations so this
is going to look like something like
this
so if board row column so this is just
indexing the matrix equals equals piece
and board row
C plus one so this is taking the next
one to the right so we're checking
horizontally so we're only changing the
columns equals equals piece and board
our c plus two equals equals piece then
finally and board this is the fourth
piece in a row board c plus three equals
equals piece then we're going to return
true so we want to return true the first
time this happens we're not going to
return this expression because that
would return that would break out of
this loop before we wanted it to okay
and so what we write again this is not
the moment the best way probably to
write it you know we have these magic
numbers popping up but it's just a very
simple way to check for all those
horizontal locations all right so let's
do the same thing with vertical
locations locations for when and
actually before I do that let's just
check to see if we can get some
functionality on this so if valid
application we're gonna also write a if
statement that says if winning move and
so we're gonna say Ford and then the
piece is 1 so if winning move we're
going to just print out player 1 wins
Congrats yay
okay let's just see if that works with
the horizontal real quick and then we're
also gonna want to set this game over
variable to true because the game is in
fact over if the move is winning so
let's just run that real quick a Python
on the current file okay clear wanna
make your section three
yeah it says player one wins and we I
guess accidentally printed the board out
won't extra time but you know we did get
that functionality it did check that
horizontal win so I think that looks
good obviously you don't want to test
these like very thoroughly but for the
sake of the time of this video I'm going
to just start going to the horizontal
the vertical location so if I think
about where vertical locations can start
you can start we need for up so I can
start it's pretty much the opposite of
the very horizontal so vertical could
start all this bottom section because we
need for up but it can be in any column
so it's gonna be pretty similar to the
last loop but we're gonna have to change
the row so you'll see in a sec shift tab
we're gonna have to change instead of
the column count doing for seeing column
count - they're gonna have to do row
count minus three because we can't start
at the top row and then we're gonna have
to add these pluses to the rows actually
row plus 1 Rho plus 2 and the last one
is row plus 3 and once again like see if
you could figure out how to manipulate
this these equations to work for any
length of a board and also let's say
maybe we wanted to make a game those
like connect 6 lie could be a cool
challenge for you guys to try to build
these functions so that they could be
any number of columns any number of rows
and any number of pieces for the winning
length okay so let's check to see if the
vertical locations now work we're going
to run this again real quick so tools
Python concurrent file three
cool it works again so we see have the
foreign row with the ones right here and
it says player 1 wins Congrats so that
looks good now we have to get to the
little bit of the trickier things we ran
out the check for the first we'll check
for the positively sloped diagonals and
we're also going to make a separate
method to check for the negatively
sloped and you'll see why we need to do
this in a sec diagonals alright so let's
think about it we're gonna think about
it the same way where our possible
starting locations that we could have a
positively sloped diagonal well we can
start here and go up we start here and
go up here and go up so I think the last
piece we can start here and go up so
this is gonna be the top row and we
can't go any farther than this piece
right here so that looks like we're
doing row count minus 3 and column count
minus 3 so just shhh
so we're gonna we'll just copy this code
see oh no what happened see and I'll
paste that in right here alright so
we're gonna have to subtract 3 from
column count and from row count and then
how this is going to increment as you
start with that initial starting
location and then we need to +1 to pull
things because it's a slope it's not
just a horizontal or vertical now so we
have to do the addition step for both of
these okay cool and as we've been doing
let's just check to see if we can get a
diagonal win here so player 1 make your
selection I'll just start in the
all right we're almost there
so close don't screw this up now Keith
okay and we'll check here cool
the diagonal there worked so that looks
like it's working too and then finally
we need to do the negatively sloped
diagonals and so if we think about
negatively sloped diagonals they can
start at the top and go downwards but
they couldn't start any lower than this
right here this is the last one they
could start at because they have to go
down four so that looks like it would be
the top rows and then also the columns
minus three so we're going to start the
rows at three and we're gonna have to
start the columns in the normal normal
location so this is going to start from
three to the row count and so it's three
because if you think about it this is
the 0th row this is the first row second
row third row so even though it's
actually the fourth up its third index
so that's why we're starting at three
and that's going to go all the way to
the top and the column counts actually
good as it is and so this is gonna have
to now go it's gonna go positively over
in the column direction but it's going
to go down a row so negative one here
negative two here and this is just a
negative slope you you know you have one
direction positive one direction
negative and this will be negative three
so let's test to see if this works
come on repeal python current file
okay I'll just build up the left side
first
[Music]
okay okay okay okay okay we're almost
into the negative diagonal there so
player one you can go three then player
2 2 then 2 cool the negative diagonals
work now - okay so that looks like we
have all the possible winning directions
you should more thoroughly test to make
sure the all the edge cases work but to
me that looks pretty good so we're also
going to implement the functionality for
player 2 in this main game loop okay so
this is player 2 player 2 when some
grads game over true okay
and if you wanted to you could just
break out of the loop if you didn't want
to see this board and the turns changing
at the end okay so that's we've now
finished the command line version of the
game
so we're gonna take this game and we're
gonna expand on it to actually make it
look nice so the first thing we're going
to do to do that is import a library
called PI game and just like the numpy
library if you don't have Pi game
installed just open up a new terminal
window and type in pip install PI game
as you can see I already have it cool
all right and now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna have to start out by
initializing PI game so this you have to
do in any Pi game project so before our
game loop starts we're gonna do PI game
done it okay and then what we're gonna
have to do is define our screen size how
big do we want our game to be so if I
real quick just build the finished
version I have you can see that you know
it's pretty you know you can kind of
break this game down into squares I
would say you have squares that
represent each column in each row and
then I had this one extra row at the top
so we're gonna define each one of those
squares as a hundred pixels so the sizes
we're going to talk about right now are
all in pixels so the square size is
going to be a hundred pixels and then
our width for our screen is going to be
the number of columns so the column
count times the square size cool and the
height is going to be the row count
times the square size and actually if
you saw my the game I just dragged in
and I'll drag it in one more time I
actually added one additional row
because I wanted this spot where I could
display this circle that I'm dropping so
we'll actually make this row count plus
one Times Square size for the height and
that will be packaged together nicely in
a variable called size which will be a
tuple of width comma height and then to
get pygame to actually read that we need
to type in the following screen
equals PI game display dot set mode and
then we'll have it read in the size and
if you're wondering where I'm kind of
just magically getting these functions
from I'm looking at the documentation on
the PI game site so if you go to PI game
dot org slash Docs you can find all the
kind of functions that I'm using I'll
post a link to that in the description
and we're going to real quick test to
see our screen is actually working so
you can just run control B as you can
see the window popped up and then it
disappeared we'll handle why it's
disappearing in a second so it looked
like though it is reading in that screen
cool
so let's now create a function called
we're do a couple things so I think
first we'll define a function called
draw board and this will just be like
print board that we defined up here but
now we're actually going to draw it with
the PI game graphic so draw board is
gonna have to take in the board and
that's about it and I'll actually pass
this for now because we're gonna make
some changes to our loop before we do
this drought board so the first major
change we're going to do to our loop is
PI game is an event based game library
so PI game kind of works and allows you
to function in the game by just reading
all of your movements of your you know
the keys you press the mouse buttons you
click the mouse like how you move your
mouse it reads those all in as
individual events so that looks like
something like this so for event in PI
game event Todd get and as I just said
events are like mouse motion mouse
button down key down etc so we're gonna
read in we're gonna drop a piece by
clicking down so that's one of the
important events we'll have to get so
we're going to first do just kind of
follow me on this one event type if the
event type equals equals pi game dot
quit
so this is just something you want to
handle in all of your games that you
make just allowing your game to properly
exit out if you click the button here in
the top right that X out X is out of it
so if that happens we have to do a
system exit just so it properly shuts
down and to get this cysts right here
we're gonna have to import that into our
project as well that means system and
that comes default in any Python
installation okay
system makes it now to get to the more
interesting stuff the event that we
really are going to care about to start
is mouse button down so if event taught
type equals equals PI game dot mouse
button down and all the different events
you can also find on the PI game website
under the docs the game is going to run
by us clicking down on a specific spot
in the screen where we want to drop the
piece so instead of reading in the
column we want to drop it in as we did
previously now this column is going to
be populated by where we click so I'm
going to real quick put all of this all
this behavior into this mouse button
down event type because now the events
of us dropping the piece always happen
when we click the mouse button down so
we don't want it to happen otherwise we
don't want it to be asking for this
input all right so column equals and
this is going to be where we click on
the screen so just for now I'm going to
just kind of comment out this stuff just
so it doesn't run on us while we're
testing control and that's just real
quick see if this fixed our error of the
screen disappearing right when it pops
up what happened
French and as you can see now we have
this screen and it's not you know it's
staying here so that's because we
actually added in this event loop here
it knows to kind of continue all these
events are happening and the exit out
will be handled properly by this the
system exit cool alright so we have our
screen looking pretty good but doesn't
have any graphics obviously so we're
gonna implement the draw board function
now so if we think about it I'll drag in
the finish one I have again we're going
to draw some sort of rectangle for each
of these slots and then a black circle
inside those rectangles and then we'll
have to draw this afterwards this piece
that we drop and then whenever we do
drop a piece the the one or two that's
in our command line based game won't
become like a red circle or a yellow
circle based on what we're doing so
let's implement this so first we're
gonna iterate through kind of every spot
in our board so for our or for we'll say
C in range column count and then we'll
do the same thing for our end range row
count just as we did above here when
we're eating through all the spots well
we need to initially just draw it as
like an open you know a blue blue
rectangle and then in that blue
rectangle we want a black circle so
we're gonna do a pie game draw function
so first we're going to draw a blue
rectangle so that looks like kind of our
game board and then the black circle
inside of that will be the open slot
we're gonna draw that on the screen and
I'm gonna drag in again the the lie the
library so I can see exactly what I'm
doing so as you can see here pygame
thought drought wrecked we need to take
in the surface the color the rectangle
we want to draw and then the width so
the screen is the surface we want to
draw it on the color is we want a blue
color so I'm going to define blue as a
global variable a global static variable
up above this is going to be an RGB
value so we're gonna say it's zero zero
comma 200 and that means or 255 or so so
that's going to be a very blue RGB value
because this means red this means green
and this means blue and the only color
that's actually has some value is the
blue here so the color we're going to
say is blue we just defined that that's
the RGB value now we didn't define our
rectangle so our rectangle is going to
be either you need to have four
different things to define your
rectangle you need to have the size of
the width and height and then also the
position so the position is going to be
this might be take a little playing
around with to get this but it's going
to be C times so these are numbers 0 2
you know the column count and 0 2 the
row count there's gonna be C times
square size because we want the actual
this is the top-left corner of it and
that's going to the
and then our position on the y-axis is
going to be R times the square size and
our height and width are going to be the
other two parameters of this what that
make up a rectangle object and that's
just going to be it's gonna be a square
so it's square size square size height
and width are the same and the width up
argument that I showed was in the
documentation as you can see it's
defined as zero so that's optional and
think that's just the outline like the
line that surrounds the square so we
don't need to implement that alright
let's test to see if just these
rectangles draw properly so down here
we'll just do a draw board taking the
board as we did here and then what we
have to do whenever we want to update
our display is do pygame dot display dot
update that will make sure that we
actually see what we're supposed to see
so we'll build that real quick oh and as
you can see we have this just giant
mound of blue and the one problem I see
right now is it's not actually opening
up the I wanted the top to be open so we
could have a piece that swings around it
so it shows us where we're dropping it
so I think the problem with that is
because our axis starts at zero zero we
actually need to to shift down by one
square size to kind of account for that
offset that we left for that space so
we're gonna have to add a square size
here now I build this again as you can
see it looks proper now we'll need to
fill in some circles to represent the
slots so we'll do that by drawing a
circle and pygame and that's also in the
documentation so we pygame got draw dot
circle and that's going to take in the
surface of a screen and now we need a
color so I think a good color would be
just black so we'll define black up
above - and black and RGB is just zero
everything zero zero zero
okay so this is black and then let's
drag in the documentation real quick to
see how we're gonna finish off this
circle so Circle Circle Circle okay
position and then radius so this is
gonna be the position of the center of
the circle as you see in the
documentation and the radius will
probably want to be a little bit smaller
than our square size just so there's the
circles aren't touching so let's define
a radius two so our radius is going to
be to find that under the width and
height and whatnot so our radius is
going to be a little bit less than the
square size so we'll do I'm gonna make
this also they have to be integer values
I believe so once we start getting into
division it might get a little bit messy
so to me int square size divided by two
because it needs to be the radius is
half the diameter and the diameter would
be the full square size and then we'll
just - an arbitrary like integer value
off of that so now we can draw our
circle with that radius but we'll have
to do the position first so the position
where is it I forget oh it's in draw
board the positions going to be so if
this the top left of the rectangle our
position for the center of the circle is
going to have to do be that then with
some offset so square size then R times
square size plus square size and the
offset is going to have to be like half
of it because we're talking about the
radius so half of the rectangle is going
to be adding an additional square size
divided by two
adding a square size / - all right let's
see what happens now oh and then
actually we have to do the actually
specify the radius so the radius is what
we define just a second ago build what
happened
yeah integer argument expected okay so
it looks like this division caused us to
have some floats in our code so we're
gonna have to actually make this int a
PI game it seems like only accepts
integers so make sure that everything
you every position and radius value you
make a integer come on baby let's go
cool the a we got a board
we'll finish implementing this graphics
we'll implement the piece dropping and
then a nice little piece fall or up here
so to start this video navigate down to
the main game loop before when we are
selecting which column we wanted to drop
a piece in we mainly typed in a number
between 0 & 6 to specify this now that
we have a graphic we want the column
that we drop the piece in to be
dependent on where we click so if I
click on the left side of the screen we
want it to drop a piece in the left
column if I click the middle the middle
column etc so where we drop the piece
depends on the x position of our mouse
pointer so luckily for us PI game makes
using the getting the x position of your
mouse super easy so if you go to the PI
game documentation under the events it
lists all of these events and then it
lists the properties you can get on
these events so for us we care about
mouse button down and we care about the
position so position gives us an x comma
y tuple of where we clicked and I can
use that as follows so I can do print
event dot position and then I can rerun
our game and so as I click on the screen
you'll be able to see in the bottom left
the positions where I'm clicking so if I
click on the top left of the screen
it's about 0 comes here that's where our
axis starts if I click on the bottom
right of the screen that's the full
dimension of our game and we specify
that to be 700 700 so these are the
pixel values of where we're clicking to
develop a kind of way to select the
column based on where we click we need
to try to find a pattern on clicking in
these different columns so I'm going to
do that real quick
and if we look at all of these clicks I
just made well you see the first click
is between 0 and 100 second click is
between 100 and 200 200 and 300 etc so
the last column is between 600 and 700
so we can somehow
these numbers down to just give us zero
to six or back at where we were when we
mainly typed in those numbers so we're
gonna do that real quick so let's we can
go ahead and uncomment all this code and
actually this is supposed to be a
comment so we can uncomment this code
right here and we can just comment this
out for now
so column so we want that to be will say
that the x position so this is a tuple
in the x values first so the position of
X is equal to event dot position and
then it's the zeroth element of that the
column now is going to be so this is
between 0 and 700 so the column we can
get using what we're gonna also just to
make this our life's easier we're gonna
import a library called math this comes
default in any Python installation so we
are going to get what we want to drop it
by doing position X then we're gonna
divide everything by a hundred because
this would give us a range between 0 and
7 instead of 0 in 700 so the first thing
we're going to do is divide it by a
hundred and 100 remember is what we
define our square size is so to make our
code a little bit more robust to changes
we're gonna do position X divided by
square size and then we want this to be
a whole number and integer value so
we're gonna have to take the floor of
this division so that will round it down
to the nearest integer so we're going to
do math dot floor and then the final
change we're gonna have to make is we
just need to make sure that the column
is an integer because we don't we can't
take the index of a float value a
decimal value so we'll just ensure that
it's integer by just surrounding with it
int and now we should be able to see
when we click on the screen we should
see our board building up and we can
copy the same thing for
player two and will uncomment this come
with that uncommon all of this and then
we'll make player to be able to select a
piece in the same way so we'll say
position x equals avenge the vent up
position 0 and then the column now oh my
god and Messi ok we'll delete this line
cool so let's see what happens when we
built the game so now we have this
where's the actual game window what
happened oh like 10 pop-up for some
reason so click down the middle if you
can see over here in the bottom right
our game did pick up that click so I
click in the middle again keep clicking
on the middle and it keeps reading that
I'm dropping the pieces in so that looks
really good now we actually have to just
represent that on the screen so to do
this we'll just make a small change to
our draw board function that draws the
graphics so navigate to draw board and
we'll just do a if statement here just
say so the rectangles always drawn the
blue rectangles that make up the board
the black circle represents the empty
square so if board
I mean board row column equals equals 0
then we want it to be a black we want it
to be empty if else if board our row
columns so this is just indexing our
matrix equals equals 1 so that's what we
see here player 1 dropped it in the
middle then we want to draw a circle so
we can just copy this line because we
know that this is in the right position
what we're just gonna have to change the
color up so we don't want it to be black
we'll just use red and yellow player 1
will be red so this is gonna be red and
this is not a built in thing
the define read so we'll define read
right below black these are RGB values
so our needs to be have a value and the
other two can be zeros so this will give
us a nice bright red and then while I'm
up here doing this I'm also going to
define yellow yellow is both red and
green as a combination of both red and
green in RGB so 255 2 3 5 0 so now we
have red and yellow for player 1 and
player 2 where was that
okay yeah it's red and then one last
line which will be the else condition
lvf board r comma or our C is 2 so
that's gonna be Pi game well actually
I'll just paste this in again pi game
and then instead of black we'll make
this one yellow and then one thing that
might not be intuitive is that whenever
we make changes to our game board after
this is all done this loop has been
iterated through we're going to want to
call pi game not display done update
that will re render to the screen with
the new changes so let is let us and
also we're gonna have to add the draw
board resort we were printing board on
every turn but we're gonna have to draw
a board here as well okay moment of
truth clicking right here
no what happened so it looks like it's
populating it's just populating it in
the wrong spot and the reason for this
is because of how our axes is set up so
as you recall when I click down on the
top left this is the zero zero and this
is the 700 700 space so in our game
though this is the zero zero piece but
it just kind of flips so when we printed
the board we call that n P dot flip
function so we're just gonna have to
figure out a way to off
that this to actually be in the bottom
of the screen as opposed to the top so
to do that we can just use our height
smartly so what we really need to do is
we're starting at the bottom so we need
to subtract whatever we're actually
trying to build up from the bottom from
our height so height minus this height
minus this let's try running this what
is happening all right so we still
having our issue and the reason we're
now having an issue is because this
piece right here is still filling in the
old-fashioned way so they're kind of
like filling in black and red and yellow
tiles all on different axes so what
we're gonna do make our life easier is
we're going to take out these two lines
into another loop so I'm you're gonna
delete those real quick and we're just
gonna do a whole nother loop of so just
try to bear with me here I'm gonna copy
this stuff we're gonna iterate through
everything again this might not be the
smartest way but it's just going to be
very clean for us to deal with because
we're always going to build our we're
always going to build our background and
then fill in the piece afterwards as
opposed to like try to fill in our
pieces as we're building the back round
so I'm thinking this will work well this
spacing is just messing me up and these
lines are so long there you go okay so
if board RC is with one we're gonna fill
it with that and then we can just delete
this line bring this back okay so now we
have two loops running but this will
kind of fix our problem of them building
our board out on different accesses so
let's try running it again what the heck
if board RC equals one we're not that
big there's an else if otherwise it's
gonna fill out the board
for all the empty spaces at the start of
the game equals two all right cool let's
see what happens now it looks like it's
working properly but it's just offset by
one square size and that's because of
this right here we are initially account
when we were building downwards we're
initially accounting for this but now
that we're building upwards we can
delete that from it from the height so
we're going to delete this square size
here we're going to delete this square
size here and we should now fully have
it working build yeah it looks pretty
good huh
all right cool so now that we've pretty
much fully implemented a game with
graphics we're gonna add a couple
additional features so the first feature
we're going to add is add this little
scroll wheel so that before we drop a
piece we can see what color the piece is
and where we're going to drop it so to
do that we're gonna add a new event
we're gonna track a new event and that's
gonna be the event type equal to PI game
mouse motion and once again all the
different events you can use are listed
in the pie the pie game documentation
and just like mouse button down the
mouse motion also has a position
property so I can do position x equals
event dot position zero so this is going
to get me a lot more events though
because it's always tracking whenever
I'm making any motion so this is gonna
be constantly updating so now we're
going to use this position and draw some
circles based on where that position is
so if the turn equals equals zero that's
player ones going then we're gonna do PI
game dot draw dot circle screen the
surface color is red because it's player
one the next thing we need to put in the
circle is the position so the x position
this is the center of the circle it's
going to be at position X wherever our
mouse is then we just want it to be
offset enough so that the full circle
can draw so we'll just make this square
size divided by two and then finally we
need to specify the height of or the the
radius of the circle and that's just the
radius we've been using for all the
tiles else this means it's turn equals
equals one it's your tutors turn and
we'll just copy this and draw it and now
it's going to be actually yellow
so let's look what that looks like if we
build that all right build okay I forgot
to get the display update just like we
did in the draw function so pi gram
don't display dot update build oh it
looks good it's just not ever deleting
the circles so what we're gonna do to
fix this is right before we actually
draw the circle we'll just draw a
rectangle that's black that will black
out any previous circles that we have
drawn so PI game dot draw dot rectangle
surfaces the screen color is black
position is gonna start at the top left
so that's zero zero it's gonna have with
the whole width of the screen and then
the height will be a square size cuz
that's how big that buffer bar kind of
at the top is and that should be good I
think I might have one extra no yeah I
have one extra parenthesis there yeah it
looks good so now we have this game over
drop drop drop drop drop that looks good
cool and so one thing that you also
might want to change is that if I win
the game so when the game real quick
with red it automatically closes right
away so one thing we can do is we can
add a weight pie game has a built-in
weight function so what we can do is if
the game over condition is true so if
game over we'll call PI game time dot
weight
and this is the milliseconds you wanna
wait so 3,000 would equal three seconds
so if I run this again one two three and
I'll shut down a manically cool and then
right before it shuts down we want a
some notification that the player
actually won so initially we were
printing it but now we'll actually
render the print function on our screen
so that will look something like as
follows so we're going to delete the
line that says player one wins and we're
gonna shil eyes a font up top so that
will look like we'll do it right below
that the first update so we'll do my
font equals PI game dot font dot system
font this is all in the documentation
I'm just copying some previous code I
wrote and the last time I wrote this I
use a font called mono space but there's
other options you can look at the
documentation for all the details and
we'll do font size 75 that's just an
arbitrary number that I found worked and
then if we go down below to actually
render that on the screen horizontally I
can type the following I can say label
equals my font dot render player 1 wins
excavation and then I believe this one
right here that i just put in specifies
the axes that it's on I'm not actually
sure I might play around with that to
check and then we want the color to be
red because it's red and during that
text red because player 1 1 and then
what we have to do to get that on the
screen we do it quickly we can also use
the PI game display that update function
but I'm going to do something a little
different here I'm going to do a screen
dot blitt and that just updates that
specific part of the screen and I toyed
around with these values before I found
that the XY pair where this will start
at the top left of corner of this text
starting at 40 comma 10 worked pretty
well so let's see what happens when I
run that we're gonna have red win player
1 wins
and the one thing is that tile gets in
the way what we could potentially do we
could potentially draw another black
rectangle if we wanted to I don't know
I'm not too bothered by it we'll fix it
in one sec we're gonna copy this for
player two and I will say player 2 wins
and the color is gonna be yellow now
build so what happens if yellow wins I'm
making this so hard on myself player 2
wins yay all right and maybe what we'll
do is at the start of the mouse button
down we will draw that black rectangle
as well so we don't have that of
annoying annoying tile getting in our
way so right before we click the mouse
button down that will make the thing
disappear or note one more time player 1
wins it looks good and you can mess
around with that as you see fit okay I
mean that's like a pretty good game I'm
pretty happy with it
if you have any questions about it leave
a comment below peace